my buddy michael irvin i decided to pop
him on during the peacock
portion of your commercial breaks
because we come back earlier on peacock
everybody should get this streamer it's
awesome
how are you michael you're good i'm
doing well buddy
i'm doing great now all right so now
you're walking from your house we've
established while we were chatting on
peacock
you're a house to a car heading to the
airport correct
i am okay yes i am just got off itc so
inside training camp
inside training camp on nfl network
michael michael irvin talking inside
training camp and i want to get to a
little bit of that what you were you
were discussing on itc
as we call it and then did you know this
chris i didn't even notice
i did not i didn't know this dropped
public now you had covid mike
you had cover oh my god rick let me see
how this thing
went too rich like what okay
when i got yeah i i got covered right
got it like
late june i got when i got back when i
got home
i didn't know i had it and then i got
real sick
i mean a pounding headache for like four
or five days you couldn't eat you can't
sleep
you just gotta endure the pain i took
two tests
they all came back negative so i'm
thinking
okay i'm good i'm good i don't have it i
don't have it but i'm
feeling the pain and then after i went
through
about three weeks of hell about three
weeks of hell i said okay
i'm going to go and take the antibody
test because it had to be
something that had to be covered there's
no way i went through that kind of pain
that kind of hell and nobody knows what
it is
because then i'm scared it may come back
so so i took the antibody test
and of course the antibody test which i
think is more accurate
came back that i did that i got to
anybody
so i can't least that's what my doctor
said
that i should be pretty good now so i i
want to come
did you you want to come yeah you want
to come to game day morning now huh um
well right i want to come to the studio
or do what we do buddy that's what i
want to do well i mean as long as you're
six feet away from me michael i'm fine
with that
um no but you know i'm done with it rich
you're good i already had it i can't get
it again i can't give it to nobody
we're good buddy me and you can sit
there we can leave kurt if we have to we
leave kurt
and coach at home but you and me we
should be right there buddy together
doing our thing
so just to recap irv
covet negative tests twice covered
antibody positive once that's what you
got right
that that that's what i got and it was
what was scary about it i'm gonna tell
you guys
i pray for anybody that has it of course
i really do
because the headache i rich let me tell
you i said to myself
honestly i'm not lying i i wanted out of
here
i was like man there's no way i could i
could even
endure this the only thing i kept saying
is you only got two weeks of it
two weeks two weeks i pray for all the
people that have those migraines
because that's it it's severe like a
migraine
and they have it all the time that would
be the hardest thing in the world
to live with because i just went through
it it was the hardest thing in the world
i've ever dealt with
ah okay so now that you've had it
okay and you know about it um would you
know
is your son is your son playing football
this fall we're i'm trying to catch up
here on
everything that's going on yeah yes he
is he is he's at fau and that's that's
interesting you bring that up because
i've talked to
a lot of the guys you know they went
back and forth right a lot of the
players
about all of that and and about covert
we had the parent call right
and and they they're doing such a great
job of trying to keep everybody informed
and everything
and and yeah like you know it's
michael's last year he's a graduate
transfer
he's with coach taggart who just came
from florida state
right and he's getting the opportunity
to catch a lot of passes so he's like
dad listen
go over to not i got to play i'm ready
to play you know
regardless and and i understood that
this is an opportunity
for him um and his last opportunity in
college so i understood
that he said i'm taking the risk right
and so um
they're gonna play fau's gonna play that
they've got they've got the
the okay to do it and you're you're fine
with the protocol as a parent you've
seen
i mean this is a hot button a subject as
there is in sports right now
is whether college is going to go right
and then you didn't you hear like the
big tents
they're trying to reconsider talking
about possibly starting october did you
hear that yes
as i said at the top of the show erv
they're trying to pull in omaha
and part of the reason why is nebraska
won't give up you know
i mean omaha is is totally
front and center in every way right now
you know that's great
you know a great
that's a great one rich pulling that
omaha back in here
omaha nebraska yeah and and
rightfully listen that i thought you
know because those kids you know all the
pressure
let me just say this there's a lot of
booster money
over that big team you got michigan
michigan state
ohio there's a lot of there's been some
pressure put down on that office you
better believe
there's been some pressure put down no i
know i'm that
but just to first bring it to you know
because we always talk real here
as you know um and david shaw who we
know very well from our our times with
the draft
i had him on monday and i i'm sure he
would point out
that the reason why they're not playing
football in the pac-12
and why they were fully agreement he
said unequivocally
when i asked him if he thinks the pac-12
made the right decision
is is because of you know the the heart
ailment that might be
brought on by covid certainly in younger
people and
myocarditis you're not are you concerned
at all about your son
obviously you're concerned but is that
something you're just like you know what
um you you've had covid so that's why
i'm
kind of bringing that up for you
absolutely i'm concerned and and in that
heart condition i'm concerned about that
as my fact that watch that interview
and you guys did a great job thanks and
i know he he's on a commit he's on the
committee yes sir he's talking right
he's on the committee
and he and he talks about that and did a
wonderful job
but but they're talking about they say
the percentage
of that percentage of people that get it
you know
is very low but of course one is too
many
you know one is too many and that's what
i think they're dealing with
okay do we we would push out the whole
season
with with the percentage of a kid
getting that being what it is and
and it's just it is so much in it rich
there's so much
there and i was joking but jokingly
seriously
serious i was just talking to some of
the kids that michael plays with and i
was saying listen
what do you do if you decide not to play
a lot of us a lot of us don't have and i
say us because i came from that don't
have a lot of great options
you know okay a lot of great options and
sometimes football
is the only way out so so rich
i started thinking to myself okay and i
said to these kids i said
you guys decide not to play where this
country is right now
unemployment is incredible i said so you
you decide not to play football
you know you don't have much at home
already and you have to go get in that
unemployment line
you'll be number 50 million in one
i'm just saying i'm just saying you know
50 million
in one so so when you start looking at
it all
i know where i came from if i was given
that opportunity and somebody said
you're happy to play or or we don't play
i'm like man you're telling me i'm
risking
catching covet and i know covert to be
hell i'm telling you i live in hell
right now and i'm trying to get out
michael irvin here
on the rich eisen show uh what'd you
make of the nba
players saying they didn't want to play
michael what'd you make of that i i i
you know i i thought
it was an incredible incredible
incredibly brave thing to do uh
uh you know we talk about it all the
time every
every superstar that comes through we
almost demand that they have foundations
and that they give back we demand it if
you don't
we demand it that's what you should be
doing that's the right that's the bright
thing to do
and that's what these players are doing
why do you create foundations rich you
create foundations because
you are blessed and you want to help
others that are less fortunate
and less blessed that's why we do all
the charity work we do
troy m and me we did a big charity
dinner the other night
you know that's why we do all the
charity work because that's the right
thing that's the right human thing and
we want to make sure it's the right
american thing
to do that's what those guys are doing
those guys are saying
listen we're trying to make sure we have
some of the people who are less
fortunate in us and and and are getting
caught in these
and getting caught in these situations a
police brutality
and and even even us in
in certain situations even us but but
but
for that charles barkley has said you
know let's be real
uh we're living a different life because
of the gifts that god has given us we're
living a different life now
but but it doesn't remove us from being
who we are
and i love that those guys say this is
still a part of me
even though i'm blessed and and living
the way i'm living this is still a part
of me and i'm going to sacrifice
for that i i thought it was inspiring
it was incredible and and kudos to those
guys
for doing that yeah and they're they're
they're coming back to uh to play
uh we had jim trotter on before in the
first hour saying that
he had just gotten off the phone our
colleague and i i'm imagining this was
part of inside training camp when you
were on the air for the last couple
hours
uh jim saying that he was on the phone
with a prominent player very prominent
player in the nfl
in tears saying he'd been crying for
three straight days about what is what
happened to jacob blake
and that he this player was considering
not playing week one in the nfl season
did you hear that one
mike yes and we talked about it and
right and i know this week
one yeah i did i heard i talked about i
heard rich and
we talked about it we talked about it
and and let me tell you what i said to
that rich please
i believe the nfl has an opportunity to
get ahead of this
you know and and i don't want to say
compromise because you don't want
anybody compromising here
on on their stance because this is
something that you don't need to
compromise on but work together
let's get let's work together and i hope
that's how when they go to the nfl go to
the players because i was worried
if the nba did not come back and i'm so
glad
you guys took the stand that they did
but i'm also so glad they came back
because it keeps the voice
where it keeps the microphones and the
cameras right where
they are right where they are so they
can make a difference and they are
making a difference but if they didn't
come back
there would have been so much pressure
put on the nfl players
to not play at all this year so they
came back
now they're back now the nfl wants to
make a statement if i'm the owner
god knows i don't have owner money but
if i am yes
i am going to go and meet with these
guys
and try here again don't use the word
compromise in a situation like this
because people are standing up for
something for serious injustice do you
work together and do something because
you can't just
sit out a nfl game and pick it back up a
couple days later because of what our
game demands
you have to have this thing orchestrated
and does the nfl
since we've had so many adjustments this
year already
do the nfl say hey let's pick week three
let's pick week four and sit down
everybody sitting down a week and then
just kind of push
everything back in recognition for what
we're trying to accomplish
for social ingestion well i mean you do
have the year of an owner
i mean you do have uh and a very
prominent one too a hall of fame owner i
mean if the dallas cowboys took the
forefront of something like this that
would certainly gain a lot of attention
mike don't you think yeah but but yeah
absolutely but i'm saying
all 32 better take the forefront on this
rich
all 32. one team because one or two
teams you got to have
everybody involved everybody involved
are it becomes a disaster if three teams
on sunday morning says you know what
we're not playing how do you make back
up those three games
you know when the other teams are
playing it it's just
it could be i mean a disaster wise for
the scheduling
of the nfl and and trying to keep the
competitive balance of the nfl
that's why i'm saying instead of putting
your head in the sand
and saying okay we hope this doesn't
happen we hope it doesn't happen
i i would be trying to get in front of
it and say let's do something about it
so we can all work together and get
something done the right way
last one for you michael before i send
you on on your day i'm sure itc was all
about tb12
talking after showing up on raymond
james winging around on a new home
stadium for him
it's tough for me to not go head over
heels for the bucks right here with
aryans being the one
at the controls with leftwich for brady
and gronk and evans and godwin
and oj howard and ronald jones and the
defense that was an
excellent run defense last year that we
have to assume is going to get better in
the past defense
it is very difficult for me not to go
head over heels
and think this is a super bowl favorite
mike what say you
well when you have 58 game winning
drives like tom brady does
you know and and how often does
an nfl game comes down come down to that
last drive
those last few seconds it it's very
understandable
why you go ahead over here let me tell
you what i love you're hearing
how tom brady is getting on guys making
sure guys are doing things perfectly
showing you know how hard that is rich
you the new dude in the locker room
the new dude in the locker room doesn't
come in and get that kind of
uh uh credibility just to be getting on
guys
out here but tom he's such the dawn
tom the dawn that nobody's everybody no
problem buddy
what you want me to do i you got six of
them i just want one of them i'll do
whatever you tell me to do
just tell me how to do it and i'm going
to do it
that's that's what i love so so so the
approach
within everything you hear and all
absolutely
you you can fall ahead over here but
just know that's a tough d
vision we'll get them week one the two
greats
tom brady and drew brees and all of
these young quarterbacks doing that
thing
we're getting them week one without any
preseason games
drew brees has been in his offense
forever tom brady with a brand new
a brand new group of guys and a brand
new coaching staff that's going to be
off the hook and then there's also the
cowboys right
yeah they're theirs who they're there
too rich and say what you will
this is what i love i do you know i love
coach gary that was my quarterback
we worked hard together we did a lot of
great things i love them i understand um
but i love hearing what i'm hearing
about mike mccarthy they turned off the
damn music
let's turn that music off so everybody
can hear and it's a seriousness
about practice this is not an extension
of the club there's no extension of the
bar
out here we come to work and i love that
he
had he got him back to pick picking up
those little small
minute details that makes the difference
between eight and eight honestly and
twelve and four
are thirteen and three small things
they're working on tj jefferson with his
arms in the air you said 13 wins earlier
this week did you not
i mean great minds think about that oh
my word me and the play man you guys
same kool-aid hey i'm telling you it's
been there mike mccarthy knows
and he he's a quarterback guru and
he comes in saying he's worked with the
guys that he's worked
not going to listen to that that's what
i i'm just excited about it man i can't
wait to see what it is when the cowboys
take the seal
and cd lamb in the mix too now with this
88
fantastic the 88 clubber michael irvin
here on the rich risen show you take
care of yourself mike i had no idea you
had coveted my god i would have called
susie and i would have called we
checked in on you and everything but you
sound uh you sound great
it's good to hear i'm so happy rich rich
and his call and text
you you can't even do any of that your
brain is stuck buddy when you
my brain was stuck so you to call and uh
or text
i couldn't have responded i couldn't
respond i would have responded
afterwards and tori hey man
i was hurt i'm good now but but i
appreciate you thinking about me you and
i you know i love you guys all right you
take care of yourself
or if you be well okay buddy okay that's
michael irvin right here
i make her didn't know that wow no idea
that's the first i've heard of that